I think we'll get started now everyone
is ening their snack
um so maybe this is the
second we
have C is the senior manager atop and
today we will be learning about how
gentic AI can help us our Ecommerce
business so let's hear from
her
right thank
you okay I hope the screen doesn't
flicker too much but you know bear with
me if it does um all right let's get
started okay so um I'm cyy I'm from
Shopify we be talking about generative
application generative AI applications
um for e-commerce um I'll start by
talking about some of the applications
that we released at Shopify um and then
I'll talk a little bit more in depth
about building um end to AI systems um
what it takes to get the right data and
how we customize LMS and then how do we
evaluate them for purpose build
applications okay so let me start with a
little bit about Shopify um Shopify is
an e-commerce platform um it Merchants
use it to build out their online store
presence
uh we have millions of merchants
worldwide 170 plus countries
represented um 10% of total us
e-commerce flows through us um and uh
about $444 billion of global economic
activity so our mission is to make
Commerce better for everyone and uh we
really want to use our data so that we
can help our Merchants partners and the
rest of Shopify make great decisions
quickly so this also Al means that we
want to democratize uh Technologies like
AIML that are typically reserved for
only the largest
companies uh we also want to tackle
challenges at scale so Commerce is
really a rapidly evolving uh landscape
and there's really no straightforward
path so Shopify is really carving out
what the future of Commerce looks like
by building world-class machine learning
systems that power experiences for
millions of merchants
okay let's start with one of our AI um
products right now so this is AI
generated product descriptions um this
is a feature that is released you can
try it out right now um one of the most
important features um for a store um and
like how we determine early early
success for a store is by how well
crafted their product pages or their
descriptions are or product descriptions
are and these product descriptions
really play a very critical role in
decision- making process for a customer
to actually make a purchase and so
improving those product descriptions can
help to drive traffic um and then they
can also increase conversions uh so this
feature actually takes in details that
you provide um it can be a product title
it can be keywords and then um it'll
generate a suggestion for a product
description it'll also offer suggestions
to rewrite that text um from an existing
description so hopefully this video
plays now
but um essentially you can have a couple
of details about the product what do you
want like a search engine to uh rank on
and the tool will automatically generate
a product description that's right
within the product setup page um
directly in the store admin uh Merchants
can generate revise expand their product
descriptions and they can have a very
consistent tone that goes all the way
across their online store and it doesn't
matter how many of the products they
offer they now just have a built-in
Wordsmith um within the admin and that
gives them more time to focus on running
their
business um okay the another example of
um where we are using AI features is in
Shopify email this is a first party app
and Merchants can create email marketing
campaigns faster um they can create
subject lines email body content um and
then they can also schedule these emails
to send at the best time that's based on
uh machine learning algorithms
determining the latest industry
Trends so I'm showing over here an
example where um Merchants can describe
what um the email is about in a couple
of words and then they can provide
details about their campaign such as
what kind of campaign goal they have or
what kind of product information they
want to add any specific keywords and
then we'll generate a suggestion for um
the subject line
here for longer text sections Merchants
can describe what they want the text to
say um they can describe the content
type so is it a sale email is it a
discount email um they can add in
product keywords about why the product
is unique or why someone might want to
actually buy it and then we can generate
the content and really the idea over
here is that now Merchants can spend
more time thinking about what makes
effective email cont content rather than
spending times time trying to find the
perfect words so when you generate text
for emails and product descriptions you
can also um add in special instructions
over here and this can specify things
like content length or format so you can
add an instruction to write content
that's maybe 40 words or less or you can
say I want the description to be written
in a different language or you can add
things like replace words with Emojis
and customizing the storefront can be
done in a very similar way everything
from the header header to the footer in
the online store editor so um this shows
you how Merchants can input some key
talking points about their product and
then they can create short form headings
over here all the way through to the
long form product descriptions that we
looked at
before
okay the last example I'll show you here
is another um Shopify app it's called
Shopify inbox um this enables a chat
interface directly on the storefront so
if a customer comes to the storefront
they click on the chat button um a
little window will open up in the
browser and it'll display a list of
frequently asked questions um and gen
these frequently asked questions are
called um instant
answers so um for merchant to set up
these instant answers uh we can
automatically generate them based on
store policies and um conversation
history so for example if a merchant
creates an instant answer that asks
about what is your return policy then um
the uh the the customer can click on
that and it'll immediately have that
answer display if there's not enough
information in the store policy or
there's not enough customer conversation
history uh then we uh generate these
FAQs based on common questions that
Merchants
receive so in all of these um writing
tasks and there's a lot of writing tasks
when you're setting up a small business
Merchants can create content that really
speaks to their brand so they have the
ability to customize the generated
content they can um keep it in the tone
of their of their and the personality of
their own brand um um and really when
generating any of these uh automatic
emails product descriptions theme texts
they can select either from the
pre-define tones or they can Define
their custom tone if they're not sure
about what tone to use they can
experiment with the tone setting and
then generate different versions um to
select which one is a good fit for their
product and their Target customer and
after selecting a tone option the
characteristics of the content will
change based on the type of tone that
was selected and this includes any um
changes in the vocabulary in the
sentence structure um or in the
punctuation of the
output okay okay so I talked a lot about
the different ways in which text
generation can benefit um Shopify
Merchants but now let's talk about how
we actually build an AI system and then
how we scale it out for millions of
users so so first I'm going to talk a
little bit about the principles that
we've learned along the way in all of
the applications that I showed our first
principle has always been that we
provide decision support not decision
making so these applications should
always assist the merchant in their
decision-making process but the merchant
always has the final say onto what goes
onto their storefront so in each of the
applications the generated content is
always always available as a preview and
the merchant gets to decide whether they
want to keep it they want to edit it or
they want to discard it in that sense we
never have the AI uh directly execute
any changes it always has to be approved
by the
merchant they also get the opportunity
to review the accuracy of all of the
content and as we've heard in like the
earlier talks today there's generative
AI makes up stuff right there's going to
be hallucinations
it's potentially going to create product
benefits that aren't real so Merchants
get the opportunity to look through what
that description is and it's really
important that they are the ultimate
decision makers about what the content
is they review the content and then they
decide to publish
it the second principle over here is
really about um how do we go from
conversation to action so conversational
Commerce is really compelling but aside
from getting some answers that um some
questions and answers or suggestions how
do you actually go from a purely
conversational interface to um something
some action is being taken so a simple
way of thinking about this is that uh
when a merchant is accepting that
content that is generated we don't then
want them to go and like copy paste this
from one screen to another screen you
actually want to execute that if they
accept it something should happen within
that storefront so that action is taking
place based on that generated
content and then finally um there's been
a lot of discussion about the pitfalls
around using generative AI with
hallucinations or
confabulations it's not deterministic
you'll get different answers every time
but I think one of the flip sides of how
this works is that it actually unlocks
creativity it is more humanlike to come
up with different answers not
deterministic answers
and so sometimes when we generate
something from these systems it can
actually be a really useful suggestion
for a future product or a product
Improvement all right so how do we
customize large language models um there
is three potential Parts in order of
complexity um we can use prompt
engineering which is essentially zero
shot or few shot learning and and um we
heard the last talk which was a lot
about retrieval augmented generation
this is Vector search across embedded
documents and then you pass that context
back through the prompt and then finally
there is finetuning where we can
directly update the model parameters and
then train on a custom data set each of
these approaches is going to require
some level of data collection from a
spectrum of the few shot learning all
the way through to a full data set that
um you can use to do fine
tuning okay so let's talk about data
collection in um in the traditional ml
world we would have spent a lot of time
collecting the data first then you build
the model you go through that ml life
cycle and iterate on the data set and
the model and then you finally release
the product with l lenss that whole
cycle gets reversed so product managers
software Engineers they can build the
product first they can release it in the
market using base llms and zero or few
shot learning and then once if that
product is successful then they can
collect real data with the released
product if that product is then scaling
they can use that real data to build a
more customized model that's going to be
specific to their use case
so if you're doing fine-tuning um the
alpaka instruction format is a really
common technique and um here I'm giving
an example of taking natural language
queries and converting them into a
custom language called Shopify ql I give
an instruction over here so this is um
describing the kind of task it is take
user instructions and turn them into a
language called Shopify ql
um I can give an example of the input um
so here the input is something like uh
how many total orders did I have last
month and then finally an example of the
expected output in the Shopify ql
language but we don't actually
know what kind of question would
generate this output so we have all of
the data about how users interact with
the system today we have the subject
matter experts that can give us really
good examples but what we don't have are
the user questions so what is the
question or the instruction or the input
that a user would ask in a gen system um
that would give us this kind of output
so that's why we actually need to build
this with synthetic
data and this is where there is another
use case for llms now you can use llms
to generate that synthetic data and one
example I'm showing over here is a
process called back translation so back
translation will start with a very small
amount of very high quality human
labeled seed data and this is generated
by subject matter experts the goal here
is to take that very small amount of
human generated data and expand it and
augment it into very very large amounts
that will improve the model performance
for your end llm application so to do
that um as I said we start with uh hand
curated input output
Pairs and then we fine-tune two models
on those really high quality pairs the
first model is a forward model um which
will go from instruction to output and
then a second model which is a backward
model um and that goes from output to
instruction so think of it as I give
100,000 plus unlabeled Pairs and that's
just the output without the instruction
and it generates that instruction so it
generates that input once I have those
two input output pairs I send it through
the forward model and that will curate
those 100,000 pairs I do this
iteratively multiple times going from
the backward model to the forward model
adding in more and more of the seed data
and that process um basically is how I
can get the highest quality examples in
my synthetically generated data set so
now you've created a very large
synthetic data set by augmenting a very
small amount of human label data and
this resting this resulting data set is
the one that you then use for actually
training your llm
application okay so one drawback that we
we have seen um with synthetic data is
that it doesn't actually look like a
conversation that you would have with a
human so I'm showing an example over
here where um if uh as a merchant if I
ask an llm a question like how do I
create a discount or what kind of
discount should I create um llms are
going to come back with a single
response here's a few different types of
uh discounts that you can create but
what I would really expect in a
conversation with a human um is to have
some back and forth so the human on the
other side might ask me some questions
based on my store they might ask me
about my business model what's the
problem I'm trying to solve and maybe
after discussing my business goals they
might uh tell me to create a buy one get
one free discount because I want to
clear out my
inventory um so this is actually what we
call a multi- turn conversation as
opposed to what you see up here and this
is like a single turn conversation so in
the absence of these real world data
points we can try another technique
which is basically two llms talking to
each other and you're training two llms
with two different personas one Persona
which has a merchant and the other
persona which is an assistant and you
can inject conversation starters so
things like how do I create a discount
or how do I
um how do I update my online store theme
and then you generate these
conversations back and forth for pre
specified number of turns and you prompt
each of the llm with the previous turn
of the conversation so it has that last
conversation history and then it's going
back and forth between two
llms all right so now we've got some
data
let's move on to customizing our llm and
we can build our
application so customizing llms um I
think we had um talked about three
different ways we had prompt engineering
which is basically by far the simplest
method and this only
requires um a handful of data points if
anything at all and it's all about
getting the model to do what you want it
to do by providing enough context
instructions and examples directly in
the prompt without changing anything in
the underlying ways we can provide
system instructions so describing what
the assistant is supposed to do you can
add in context about the user so what's
their time zone what kind of plan are
they on um add an additional context
about the tasks so what can be done on
the page or you can add in successful
output um and then what this does
require is like a few different
iterations depending on that application
because that llm knowledge is static so
this is one of those cases where you're
most likely to see hallucinations or
outdated
information and there's a couple of
different ways in which you can do
prompt engineering to prevent
hallucinations so lots of different
techniques available here I'm just
showing one of them which is a popular
way of doing this which is called Chain
of Thought and this can elicit more
reason responses so instead of just
giving an example of a successful in
input output pair so you know there's
some math question here and just the
answer um you can also show the
reasoning behind how somebody arrived at
this answer so kind of like when you're
in school and you have to show your work
that's what this um Chain of Thought
prompt is like uh and this has been
shown to be pretty successful in terms
of show uh reducing
hallucinations um we heard about
retrieval augmented generation uh prompt
tuning works really well when you're
working with small amounts of data sets
but um if you have a really large
repository of data um you'll run out of
tokens in the context window very
quickly and then you you won't be really
able to pass all of that information
directly to the llm through the prompt
so that's where retrieval augmented
generation comes in and this method um
it allows us to augment llms with custom
data um it's still a method where you're
passing in information through the
prompt but it's powered by um document
embeddings and a vector search um that's
only going to pass through the most
relevant documents or the most relevant
document fragments and that goes through
into the prompt it's passed on to the
llm and then that generates the
response um this is actually a really
great technique when the underlying data
is dynamic or uh facts are evolving over
time so for example if if you're
building something like a help center
assistant um that always needs access to
the most recent data then um having
those regularly updated help talks um
can uh feeding in through this embedding
solution can be the right solution
here okay so let's talk about fine
tuning um fine tuning updates the model
parameters uh using the data set that
you provide and it'll try to capture the
distribution of tasks based on that data
set this does require assembling um a
data set with all of the things that
traditional ml had so do you have a
balanced data set do you have
stratification do you have the right
coverage based on the task that you're
trying um trying to get the llm to do um
it does require ground truth data uh and
then there's many different ways of fine
tuning I'll talk about one of them um in
the next couple of slides but one of the
things to note um here is is that these
base models are really improving at a
break neck speed um GPT 4 released in
March and llama 1 was in June and by
July we had llama 2 with 7 billion 13
billion 70 billion
parameters um at the same time context
windows are also very rapidly increasing
so this means that um you can just add
this you know data sets directly through
the prompt you never need to actually
get to find tuning
um okay so let's start with some
classical fine tuning uh I'm going to
start with classical picture of is it a
bagel a muffin or a dog um we've seen
this a lot of times before and uh
basically what I want to do is um
instead of uh just having a bagel or
muffin classifier I want to add in
another category for chaha so how would
I go about doing that I don't actually
need to just like throw away my model
and and start from scratch uh what I can
do is I can add a layer uh so I can add
a new hidden layer over here that will
represent the missing information um
that that I want the model to learn and
I I okay I can freeze hidden layer one I
can unfreeze hidden layer two and then I
can train all of this together so now I
have my new hidden layer and my um and
my classification layer that is going to
be trained and updated those weights uh
adding that new um Chihuahua category to
the mixture pretty standard um classical
fine tuning how do I do this with with
um
llms um with llms you have you can you
have for especially for the open source
type you have the um choice to update
more than one fully connected layer or
in some cases you can also just update
the entire all the layers including the
pre-trained transport for but where the
challenge is now is that um with
updating a full pre-trained model we
require a lot of large data um so this
can potentially actually be increasing
proportionally with the number of
parameters right so as the SI the size
of the model increases the amount of
data you might need will also increase
and overfitting then becomes a risk
because you're talking about 70 billion
parameter model
and whatever data set you have um the
other concern that happens here is as
you um start training with very high
volumes of data this can lead to llms uh
experiencing something called
catastrophic forgetting so they're
trained on this new task with your high
amounts of of data and they've forgotten
how to do the other tasks that they were
trained
on um and short of a few companies that
can afford it this is a very
computationally expensive um
solution
um so how can this be done um one of the
very common set of approaches is called
uh parameter efficient fine tuning um
and low rank adaptation is one of those
uh approaches uh this is also known as
Laura so in Laura the original
pre-trained weights are not updated what
we do is that we add a pair of rank
decomposition matrices these are called
update matrices um and we only update
these uh these newly added weights so
this means that um the number of the
updated parameters is actually an order
of magnitude smaller uh and so
consequently the volume of data that you
require is also an order of magnitude
smaller um not all of the llms allow us
to have this much control um so here I'm
showing an example of of um using Laura
with Lama 2 model um you can uh pick the
model size you can choose the L uh the
Laura configuration um and essentially
what this allows for is that it's
reduced computational cost um faster
training time uh and uh reduced
overfitting um so you you'll have a lot
of choices in terms of how do you pick
the right model or the right config um
it's really important to work through
how to train these models um to be
effective at the task so they come in
lots of different sizes architectures
should you use GPD 3.5 four uh GPD 4
llama with 13 billion parameters 70
billion parameters and I won't go
through this whole slide because I'm
being told that I'm running out of time
so really it just comes down to
experimentation um the questions that
you might have about how much data is
required
uh what's the optimal size of the Laura
what kind of layers should I be updating
all of this is um essentially an
experimentation
task okay so we had the data and the
model uh we don't know if this is
actually going to do a good job um in
production so how do we actually
evaluate
llms first you're going to need an
annotation system so synthetic data is a
good starting point but it doesn't
replace the value of user generated
content so when um users generate this
content it's going to be really noisy
and um this is an example that I'm
showing off The annotation system for
from open AI uh human labelers would
give scores and they rank the
responses um and then one of the really
important things over here is that The
annotation system needs to be able to
correct the responses because this is
what is actually going to be fed back to
update your find tuning data um so that
you have correct uh higher quality data
that's actually going back
in um and then you there is a difference
between model evaluation and system
evaluation so before this gets into the
hands of users you want to make sure
it's passing both types of
evaluations um the in the case of model
evaluation this is where you're trying
to choose between the different types of
models and in the case of system
evaluation this is where you're trying
to understand the end to-end performance
of all of the components from input to
Output so what happens if I change
something in the prompt um or if I
change something in the context or the
grounding data there's standard NLP
metrics for model evaluation like token
accuracy word error rate and so on um
but system evaluation really requires
some
customization um so one of the ways for
uh doing system evaluation is in the
absence of hand curated data you can ask
another llm to grade the output and
things like if there is a question
answering um task then the llm evaluator
can check if the response is correct um
whether it's concise um or uh relevant
to the question we can design task
specific evaluations and this is looking
at domain specific language is it using
the right syntax and so on and finally
you can also check completeness of the
response um is there information in the
input that's not in the
output um this is an example of open a
evals so if you do have an expert answer
available uh llm evaluator can then
check the factual content um it can see
if this the answer and the expert answer
the so the response from the llm and the
expert answer compare um whether it's a
subset a superet um whether it contains
all the details uh or if there's a
disagreement between these
answers okay so we covered a lot and I'm
going to put this all together now um we
started off with a prompt and a query
and for tasks that had D Dynamic data we
can search a vector database for
Relevant documents and
information we can take the extracted
enhanced context add that to the prompt
um llm Can summarize that information
and then that out to the user um to uh
for with the generated response and then
for tasks that require fine-tuning um we
have we can generate synthetic data
that's uh in the absence of real data we
fine-tune that base model um if it
passes your evaluation you can put it
into production and if all the um send
it back to the llm generate the response
and so on and now all of the responses
whether it's coming from rag or fine
tuning or prompt will then go into your
your offline annotation system where uh
human subject matter experts can update
that uh update that uh data send the
corrected response back to your fine
tuning and continuously improve your
system so um in navigating all of these
complexities we've been collecting data
model fine tuning ux design the one
thing that we've learned along the way
is that to make this technology feel
like magic is really the ongoing path
and we've made a lot of strides in terms
of the Gen applications that we have out
in production we really want to empower
Merchants with AI systems that aren't
just sophisticated but they're also
trustworthy and then they can easily
integrate them into their daily
operations all right um thanks for
listening to my talk we are hiring so
please get in touch if you're interested
in um this
topic
um thank you everyone so if anyone have
any questions you can
just go for
it any memorable hallucinations you'd
like to
share um
definitely had lots of hallucinations
with like pricing and things like that
but that's what we trying to J Ste away
from those uh types of
issues did your did your F tuning work
without ground data or like howal ground
data is actual
data fraction of it significant it's not
easy to get that yeah I think it is
really important to have the very high
quality you do need to have um you do
need to have the really high quality
seat data or data that was handcrafted
um by bymes first and then you augment
that data so yeah so you don't need like
the web CW the Wikipedia like those data
sets are not that NE only just like a
portion of the yeah these are uh the
fine tuning data sets are going to be
specific to your task so there so for
when I was giving an example of Shopify
ql Shopify ql is a structured query
language that is used for um
specifically for Shopify related queries
that Merchants can use on their own data
sets and it's different from SQL in the
sense that it's abstracted away um so we
have to create our own fine tun data set
specifically for that task of going from
natural language to Shopify ql for
example
for training
for and found using back translation so
I use back translation I also like based
I found it back
translation sometimes I really couldn't
trust in words like
I
different so I wonder what your
experience yeah it um that's very true
so again even with back translation
really just depends on the second part
of that step so the forward model that
is then doing the curation and the
curation part is actually prompt based
so you can tune that um the the curation
um to do a better job with that prompt
as well both of them are fine-tuned
models but one thing I would recommend
would be to to try out different prompts
for that um curation forward model um I
think the second part that you said it
is it is a problem because you'll often
get questions that don't sound humanlike
so that was the most common thing that
occurs when generating the synthetic
data sets using something like back
translation or even with llms talking to
each other is there is a uh to generate
a high quality data set is a very high
bar it's very difficult to get
that so thank you everyone thank you for
being such a wonderful listener thank
you for us gratefully for our insightful
information